hi everyone today I would talk about
long-term potentiation in details one
significant feature of our brain is its
ability to change throughout its
lifetime depending upon experiences and
our brain is composed of billions of
neurons connected to each other like
junctions known as synapses and
depending upon learning or memory
related tasks or when we came
experiences the strength of these
synapses change and the strength of the
synapses could increase or decrease this
alteration of the synaptic shamed as to
synaptic strength is known as synaptic
plasticity and if the synaptic strength
has increased the transmission
efficiency of the synapse has increased
over time then we can call it
potentiation and some kind of
potentiated synaptic response could last
for even days to hours and that is
termed as long-term potentiation in
hardly 1960s Timothy bliss and tortured
or devised a protocol which can alter
strain between the synapses but how did
they measure the altered strength
between the synapses they stimulated the
priests in amps and was able to record
from the post synapse now when they
injected a small amount of current in
the presynaptic terminal they found that
from the post synapse they could record
the excitatory postsynaptic potential
which is epsp which is basically a
voltage deflection now they can give
high-frequency stimulation and after
high-frequency stimulation once they
again applied the same amount of
injected current they are able to get
increased amplitude of the postsynaptic
response suggesting synaptic strength as
all red
it is increased that's that's why same
of current can give rise to even bigger
voltage deflections another way of
understanding this data is to calculate
the slope of this EBS B now the slope
would be increasing
if the synaptic strength has increased
you can see here is the point when the
high frequency stimulus was given and
after that the slope of the epsp is way
above them then in the normal situation
that means there is something inside a
hidden message inside the high frequency
stimulus that is allowing her long
lasting change in synaptic strength and
you can see the synaptic strength
alteration could last for even several
hours now what Timothy bliss and turn
shalom or did they took hippocampus from
rabbits and they cut certain sections
such that they can get a slice where
they can record from the hippocampal
region and she is the kind of model
setup that probably could be used record
from the hippocampal slices to stimulate
the perforin pathway which is coming
from the internal cortex and this
performant pathway just posting up to
this perforin pathway is dentate gyrus
training cells they place their
recording electrode to the dented
china's granule cells and stimulated the
porphyrin pathway and then exactly use
the protocol that i have discussed
previously stimulated first they were
able to record when they give a 100
Hertz high-frequency stimulation for 4
to 5 times and again they injected small
amount of current that they have
injected earlier and each time they have
observed that the epsp slope has
increased suggesting the synaptic
strength is altered now the synaptic
efficacy is increased synaptic
transmission efficiency has increased
and it's lasting for quite a lot of
hours so this kind of change
they have termed as long-term potent
because it is long-lasting increase in
synaptic strength now their discovery at
early 1960s created a huge impact on
neuroscience field because at the same
time people knew that hippocampus could
be very important for formation of
memory from the patients who don't have
hippocampus or lost their hippocampus
during any kind of accidents has
impaired memory or they fail to form new
memories that created a huge impact that
time because people know hippocampus is
important and at the same time we shall
know more found that hippocampus
strength hippocampal synaptic strength
could be altered by high frequency
stimulus people ask the question that
whether high frequencies the LTP
protocol that they used whether it is
the same kind of proto same kind of
mechanisms are used inside our brain to
incur encode the memories and indeed
these LTP protocol has good
computational advantages like it has
input specificity that means the synapse
which is stimulated with high frequency
stimulus is only getting potentiated
only the synaptic strength is altered
which is selectively stimulated not the
other one and cooperativity means
potentiation in one synapse would
increase the chance of potentiation in
the nearby synapses that means they
there is some degree of crosstalk so all
these properties are attractive
properties which could be used by our
brain to encode memories later people
found that such mean learning tasks
where our mouse has to go to a box and
where they are given a shock so this
kind of conditioning is known as
inhibitory avoidance conditioning where
the mouse would learn to avoid this kind
of chamber so underline this kind of
behavioral task people found a long
lasting change in the synaptic strength
suggesting LTP like phenomena is also
valid
underlying
mechanism of learning or or experience
related behaviors that means this
particular mechanism could be used the
mechanism the molecular mechanisms
underlying LTP would be used by our
brain to encode or to store memories now
what is so magical about this high
frequency stimulation what hidden
message does it have that is read by the
cells to write plastic changes well one
of the very interesting fact about LDP
is it is dependent upon NMDA receptor
and coincidence detection let me
describe what is coincidence detection
and what is the role of NMDA receptor in
it now when a presynaptic action
potential reach its terminal it would
allow vesicle release and let's say it's
a glucometer chick synapse and the
neurotransmitter is glutamate so
glutamate would bind to the glutamate
receptors one type of Ramat receptor is
amp receptor other type is nmd both are
ionotropic that means they are ligand
gated ion channels but in empty receptor
doesn't open when glutamate is bound to
it because there is a magnesium block in
the intracellular side now after AMPA
conduct sodium which would in turn make
the postsynaptic membrane more
depolarized repelling the magnesium
block out now the NMD receptor can
conduct and it could allow calcium
influx so what NMDA receptor does is
NMDA receptor convey the message about
coincidence it tells them snaps the
prison apps and posts in apps are
simultaneously active the presynaptic
activity status is can were conveyed by
the presynaptic Mohammed receptor
binding you do remain pointing to the
NMDA receptor and the postsynaptic
the postsynaptic magnesium block
repelling conveys the message about
postsynaptic activity status so
presynaptic and postsynaptic activity is
coupled at the level of molecules such
as an MD and that give rise to
coincidence now if you block in MDS
the principle part by which coincidence
detection can happen then people have
found that the potentiated response
after a high frequency stimulus is gone
in a control situation when an MD
receptor is active and there is no
blocker after high frequency stimulation
there is potentiated response and it is
expressed in terms of percentage of
baseline slope but in case of NMDA
receptor when the NMDA receptor is
blocked by pharmacological agent the
potentiation is gone but people have
also found that that the animal in which
the NMDA receptor was blocked by
systemic injection of pharmacological
agent with which block in MD receptor
there also the mouse poorly performed in
spatial navigation tasks in Morris what
remains now clearly we understand that
NMDA receptor and NMDA receptor-mediated
calcium influx is very important for
change in synaptic strength for change
in long-lasting synaptic strength so
what is inside the calcium dynamics what
messages does calcium has which can
translate to functional change or which
can alter the synaptic efficacy it turns
out that the calcium spatial temporal
dynamics can hold specific information
that information could be in turn
decoded by molecular players like camp
k2 or ass and etc so in this video I
would talk about a little bit about
capital but before we go there we should
understand whether calcium elevation is
at all necessary for long-term
potentiation or not people early
research has shown that when people
stimulated the perforin but they can
record from the granule cells and in
normal situation people can find find a
potentiated response but when they block
calcium in the post synapse by putting a
calcium generator this they found no
potentiation happens
suggesting calcium is important
postsynaptic calcium elevation is
important for long-term potentiation now
in order to show that this is sufficient
people have given an engaged people have
engaged gates calcium in the
postsynaptic region
now after on gating of the calcium in
the post synapse has increased the
synaptic strength that means calcium is
both necessary and sufficient for
long-term potentiation now what we saw
is if we inject a current from the [ __ ]
naps we are going to record a response
now here we give a 100 Hertz high
frequency stimulus repeatedly for 4
times now what molecule phenomena
happens underlying this hundred Hertz
high frequency protocol so after high
frequency stimulus you are going to get
a potentiated response because in a
calcium and cam kinase dependent manner
lot of ampere mediated vesicles are
going to dock onto the postsynaptic
membrane which would allow more and more
hamp receptor to be displayed on the
postsynaptic membrane which would hugely
increase the ampere currents and
increase the probability that NMDA
mediated calcium could easily get in and
thereby altering the synaptic
transmission efficiency you can clearly
understand after a hundred Hertz
frequency protocol the the strength of
the synapse has altered because lot more
ample receptors are on the surface and
you can record a boosted postsynaptic
current or postsynaptic potential the
researchers have shown that after after
LTP protocol there is a increase in
volume and also there is an increase in
postsynaptic current and this increase
is restricted to the spine that is
stimulated that means restricted to the
synapse which undergoes a high
frequencies
stimulus but nearby spines which doesn't
undergo high frequency stimulus doesn't
show any potentiated response this also
suggests and proves that long-term
potentiation is input specific now
people found that underline calcium the
cam k2 activity is very important for
truly important for plastic changes now
people can selectively stimulate with
the advancement of new technologies
people can selectively stimulate
synapses and can monitor camp k2
activity in real time by zero since
resonance energy transfer now what
people have found that cam k2 activity
lasts for a few seconds roughly about 60
seconds and off just after camp k2
activity there is a correlated increase
in synaptic volume that suggests camp k2
activity and functionally and
structurally alter the synapses and cam
k2 activity is downstream to calcium and
high frequency stimulus so again see
here is the high frequency stimulation
and after the high frequency stimulation
when we give the initial current
injection what we have used earlier
there is now neurotransmitter release
from the presynaptic and bind even more
glutamate receptors than earlier it
would allow sodium to influx it is now
easy to make the post synapse
depolarized and thereby repelling the
magnesium block and thereby allowing
calcium influx for this region for this
particular diesel what we saw is there
is an increased postsynaptic potential
or postsynaptic current because now
there are more channels getting inserted
due to the membrane also that I haven't
discussed this can can do can
phosphorylate specific and percept and
thereby greatly enhancing their
conduction efficiency now more amount of
sodium can come in from those receptors
which are phosphorylated
which is another mechanism of LTP now
how to understand that more and more
ample receptors are inserted into the
postsynaptic membrane so what people
that does is people stimulate the
presynaptic ORD from the post synapse
and they calculate something called amp
IMD ratio now after high-frequency
stimulation what people have found that
amp inm D ratio has increased that means
more ample receptors are inserted which
would make it easier to activate the
NMDA receptors and thereby conducting
calcium through NMDA receptors now not
only so we also we found that that high
frequency stimulus and downstream to
have a frequency stable as calcium camka
- all these can change the functional
properties of the synapse can change
this transmission efficiency of the
synapse but it's also true that synaptic
volume is also increased after high
frequency stimulus
let's just see what what possibly could
happen our underlying high frequency
stimulus scientist has found out that
just like can't get to activity another
small row gtp is activity CTC 42 is
restricted to dendritic spine and camka
2 can phosphorylate cdc42 and cdc42 is
well known to regulate r23 activity and
the series 42 can regulate acting
branching acting polymerization etcetera
etcetera which could ultimately allow to
increase in spine volume thereby we can
understand that how long-term
potentiation
can give rise to functional and
structural changes at the level of
synapse how calcium is important in this
process and how NMDA receptor can detect
coincidence and thereby greatly enhance
synaptic strengths but the question then
it's really really a open question in
the newer in neuroscience is whether LTP
is
or not but they found good correlations
and good computational properties of LTP
which which which which could make LTP
as an attractive model of memory
encoding but still people believe that
high frequency stimulus is too high for
a physiological situation let's say when
we test an ice cream we still remember
the taste of the ice creams still now
but does that ice cream give rise to
that high frequency stimulus people
really don't know so there are also
contradictory views against LTP so but
still people believe that the molecular
mechanisms underlying LTP could be used
by our brain to encode memories hope you
enjoyed my video so if you like my video
give it a quick thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe and if you if
possible please share thank you thanks
for watching